(whooshing sound)
(lively music)
Salman: So notice that when
the X term was positive,
our hyperbola opened to
the right and the left.
Voiceover: Sal Khan is the CEO of
nonprofit on-demand educational resource,
Khan Academy.
He started making educational videos
and compatible practice software in 2004
for his cousins, that offer lessons and
many levels of mathematics and science,
and they became viral,
with many more people turning to him
and asking him to create even more
lessons in a variety of areas.
Now, he is doing it full time,
and Khan Academy is a designated
Forbes Name You Need To Know in 2011.
A recent blog post on Khan's
new approach to education,
which takes the lectures
out of the classroom,
leaving more room for
project-based learning at school,
sparked quite the conversation online.
Salman: Bruce Upbin brings up the point
that there is not a chance on Khan
Academy to ask follow-up questions.
I think, at least the
way I think about it is,
let's say you have a question,
and you're doing calculus,
you have a question on limits.
There is a video on limits,
and you can go back and you can
click that 10-minute video on limits,
and just the act of that is, like,
"You know what?
"I don't understand limits.
"Can you explain a
little bit more on that?"
And if you're still stuck,
if you don't even know how to navigate
or know what you should be looking
at to answer your question,
we have a pretty vibrant community.
We have a million users a month.
So to Bruce's second point
about hands-on learning,
it's a completely fair point.
And I think what Khan Academy enables
is more time in the classroom
for actual hands-on learning.
The students are getting the
lecture at home at their own pace.
They can remediate if they need to.
And now they can go to the classroom
and do project-based learning
and spend more time with the professor.
To Kerckhoff's point about
taking a relationship
or connection with the teacher
to really get deep understanding,
I think that's true.
I think we'd be very optimistic
if we think a lot of the students
are getting that deep intimate
connection in the classroom right now.
I think most students aren't.
And to some degree, and even though
it is virtual, it is strange,
but I get a lot of feedback
from a lot of users
that they feel a deep
intimate connection with me,
that I feel like their
neighbor or their older brother
and that I'm sitting next
to them at the kitchen table
teaching them math.
I love Christopher Helman's point,
and I'm glad I was able to help his wife.
To his point about replacing universities,
I don't think that's going
to happen anytime soon,
but I think it's an interesting idea.
I think to think about that,
we have to realize that a
university is two things:
It's a credential and it's learning.
I think Khan Academy is
going to be able to really
change how the learning part is
done in a pretty significant way.
The credentialing part, getting your
degree from Stanford or Harvard,
that will probably be
there for a little while.
I think if you fast
forward 10 years from now,
I mean it's not going to happen overnight,
I mean this is a social change happening,
10 years, 20 years,
I think an employer would rather see
your log from a site like Khan Academy,
where it doesn't just get
a 3.2 GPA in psychology,
it gets what you did, when you did it,
how well you did it, how well
were you able to help your peers,
how consistently did you work.
"Wow, this guy worked three hours
everyday for 20 years on this stuff."
"This is a persistent kind of
guy that I want working for me,"
and we'll be able to give
people that type of analytics.
I think that could be a
more powerful transcript
than just a high-level degree right now.
(whooshing sound)